[Music]
with way over a hundred missile shot in
they didn't shoot one down the equipment
didn't work too well their equipment
every single one hit its target we were
not looking for war we wanted to send a
strong message that they needed to stop
the chemical weapons program that
message was heard loud and clear around
the world we believe we degraded their
ability to use chemical weapons to kill
people Syria reaction around the world
to the strikes 105 missiles the
president saying all hitting their
targets none shot down by the Russians
here's the British Prime Minister this
was not about intervening in a civil war
and it was not about regime change it
was about a limited targeted and
effective strike that sought to
alleviate the humanitarian suffering of
the Syrian people by degrading the
Syrian regime's chemical weapons
capability and deterring their use okay
back with the panel critics on both
sides Olivier some saying this shouldn't
been done in the first place others
saying it didn't go far enough and
didn't push the buttons that they needed
to push so according to the Pentagon if
you take their of their account of this
strike it was very tactically successful
all 105 missiles found their targets
they showed us the targets destroyed the
question though now becomes what happens
to the strategy there's right now the
u.s. strategy in Syria ISM bid is pretty
muddy we had secretary Tillerson earlier
this year describing an expansive terms
an effort to achieve a political
solution to contain Iran and of course
to finish the job but defeating Isis
then we had the president saying that we
were going to get out of Syria as soon
as possible even while across town the
general running the war said late I was
laying out the reasons for staying then
we had the French president saying more
recently yesterday in an interview that
he'd convinced President Trump to stay
in for the long term which the White
House them characterized as well there's
no timetable exactly but we still want
to get out so for the question for me
right now is what is the American
strategy in Syria is this a one-off is
this it was tactically successful but
what happens to the strategy now well I
think you are seeing a lot of pressure
for this to be made into something
bigger you see interventionists on both
left and right who are upset that this
wasn't a bigger strike that they wish
that more was happening here but I think
that I read Thomas listen put it well
he's called it a Goldilocks strike not
too cold not too hot but just right not
too much to invite aggression not too
little to invite them to continue to use
chemical weapons
the instincts that Trump had which were
to stay out of Syria he seems to still
be pushing for it against all this
criticism who want him to get more
involved and be more embroiled in yet
another Middle East conflict those
instincts are probably right that he has
right to pick up on the president's
instincts we learned two things here one
we've known that he's been contradictory
about this and conflicted himself about
what are you resisting going in talking
just weeks abut go about getting out of
Syria but then responding to these
pictures that we saw here on special
report again and again the personal
connection the emotional case is what
carries of the day if you're in briefing
this president and then second we saw
the president went with his generals and
time and again on national security
questions this president has been in the
40-yard lines of Republican national
security policy and we saw it again he
wanted to go bigger the emotional
response he stuck with what the
Secretary of Defense general mattis was
recommending more than if it more
restricted and also that speech was
pretty comprehensive I mean it was laid
out what on the night of the strikes it
kind of said we're not in it for the
long haul we're not gonna be there
forever but this needs to stop these
chemical weapons the question about the
sanctions and whether nikki Haley was
over her skis or whether there was some
confliction about whether they were
going forward with more sanctions or not
what do you think about that well I
think that it's rare actually to
announce the precise day when you're
rolling out economic sanctions because
you don't want to Telegraph you're
moving by this point prominent Russians
have to know what's coming
she did get a little bit out of her over
her skis but it's what struck me was it
is it is rare to announce this stuff it
also highlighted something which is
there's a difference between the Trump
administration Russia policy and Donald
Trump's policy towards Russia where the
administration they're pretty tough and
if you look at issue after issue let me
just take one providing lethal defensive
aid to the Ukrainians for example
something the Obama folks resist yet out
of concerns that it might escalate the
conflict there that's a big step and
then you mean the focus is why these
sanctions didn't come on does it have to
do with Russia but there's no like
looking back and what actually has
happened when there are so many
sanctions placed on individuals or
corporations in Russia that doesn't get
a lot of media coverage we hear all this
about supposed to come from
that is binding the president but when
he actually does take a hard line
against these people and not and you
could be harsh against Russia without
actually wanting to go to war against
Russia - and this is an occupational
hazard of being a trump cabinet member
or administration official it's clear
is Olivia suggested she was articulating
the administration consensus at that
moment